êtes vous heureux moi non pas pour la
grande majorité de ma vie j'ai passé
plus d etat de mahler est de plus en
plus que j'avais du succès dans la vie
tout le monde dit soyons très chanceux
tu viens chien qui vit à las vegas
tu prends l'avion est à bruxelles ce
fils que tu veux tu veux ou tu veux mais
le plus que j'avais du succès le plus
que ça me rendait malheureux c'est drôle
dès mon jeune âge je savais qu'il y
avait un problème il y avait un trou je
ne fais pas dans mon petit village
j'ai aucun traumatisme demande dans mon
jeune enfance j'ai des bonnes parents
mais je suis parti à la quête du bonheur
il fallait que je trouve le trou qu'il
manque dans moi c'est tout
l'or s'est accumulée toute ma vie adulte
à travers tout mon succès avec
l'événement le plus traumatisant de
toute ma vie j'ai dû m'asseoir un après
midi
regardez mon fils dans la plante des
yeux et lui expliquer que dorénavant ils
à avoir deux maisons ce site est le
moment le plus profondément malheureux
de toute mon existence
dans ces moments là ça ça doit tenir aux
fils d'al azhar 2,7 moment là qu est ce
qui est arrivé c'est le plus gros bon
cadeau de ma vie qui s'est ensuite c'est
un fait un peu plus que dix ans
maintenant et depuis ce jour là j'ai
consacré chaque moment l'hébreu à la
recherche du bonheur c'est pas quelque
chose
ce que j'ai trouvé le science m'a aidé
un petit peu pour la raison simple que
j'ai essayé tout ce qui existe aux
ventes vous voulez connaître la diète
vous voulez connaître le livre vous
voulez connaître la fad du moment je les
ai tout fait pour ceux dans la salle qui
me connaissent je suis un petit peu int
ans comme personne
je suis laboratoire j'ai fait tout ce
qui existe pour trouver le bonheur
les sciences est venu m'aider beaucoup
avec des choses quand j'ai découvert que
il ya quatre émotions qu'ils règlent
tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
nous nous avons là par excusez moi mon
fils le plus gros peur de toute ma vie
la région pas en quel plus d'enlèvements
d'enfants au monde
le rapport de chypre j'ai perdu mon fils
pour 30 minutes dansé thériault parle je
peux vous dire que je check justin
dépenses
leclerc qui ce ne soit pas représenté
les vins il se poser des tristes mais je
vais le regarder parce que autant qui
est triste ce bar hante chaque tout
d'abord dans le coeur quand je vois un
bébé comme ça je fais une distinction
très profonde
inde le plaisir qui peut être une folie
et la joie vous ai vraiment qui sur les
quatre motions de base
il ya trois qui sont négatifs qui a une
qui est positif pour nom voici l'ennemi
mortel de l'humain nous sommes est
lumineuse à la fois des vins qui vit
dans un corps animal qui évolue depuis
quelques millions d'années dans cette
colonne nous avons une partie du vieux
sur vos puis je veux continuer à parler
du corps animal pour le reste de la
présentation cet cerveau animal est
programmée à la base point est négative
vous avez entre 50 et 70 mille pensées
par jour
si vous saviez pas donc la majorité sont
négatives si pas de votre faute pour le
mien c'est crédit comme ça à l'intérieur
du corps plage de votre cerveau animal
donc comment est-ce qu'on puisse
travailler avec une machine qui n'est
pas positif à la base bon premièrement
j'ai trois hypothèses dans la science
qui prouvaient j'ai à peu près 75 pages
de textes parce que je suis atteint de
la même maladie qu en dehors de ma
maladie
le sourire pourquoi le sourire je vais
dire le fera si vous n'avez pas remarqué
mon accent ne proviennent pas de
lac-saint-jean ça provient de l'île
tropiques de terre-neuve
ouais c'est ça cependant le sourire
savez vous que vous avez pas besoin
d'être heureux pour souriez dingli en
chine a fait une conférence incroyable
sur le bonheur en expliquant que les
sciences du sourire faire en sorte que
si on forme les muscles si on travaille
les muses pas souriez le cerveau inonde
s'inonde de dopamine toutes sortes
d'endorphines qui fait en sorte qu'à un
sou rien les muscs envoie une marche
mais ce message ou une massage en dix
ans elle vous êtes heureux
bon on va mettre des endorphines donc le
plus que vous souriez le plus que vous
allez être heureux c'est pas naturel
au début ce programme met un crayon d'un
j'ai ainsi d'être sérieux cette expo est
sérieux dans le début
non votre hypothèse numéro 2 waouh je ne
vous vois pas malheureusement comme un
chevreuil dans les lumières d'un vergne
plus que vous le pensez
la respiration qui ici dans la salle ad
je fais une formation sur la respiration
voire excellents la respiration est la
base de tout si vous maîtrisez pauvre
respiration vous êtes en train de vous
ou toxiques et toute la journée
voici un petit peu pourquoi dans l'air
que vous respirez lié jusqu'à 15%
d'oxygène donc ça va déjà mais en
partant
si vous ne faites pas comme on me dit
souvent la maison respirer par le nez
vous avez très peu d'oxygène qui
rentrent à l'accord si vous saviez vous
allez le savoir maintenant si vous
comprenez vous avez pas qu'on veut c'est
quoi le taux de ph dans un corps c'est
très important d'aller lire là dessus
mais si vous ne resterez pas comme il
faut vous vivez dans un corps incident
un camp incident veut dire un camp qui
accueille de la politique donc leur
respiration en dehors de nos propres
glineur en dehors de toutes sortes
d'autres choses
médicalement parlant vous devez vivre
dans un corps sienne si vous voulez être
heureux donc la respiration est à la
base de tout numéro 3 on va rentrer dans
cette villa qui m'intéresse le plus
premièrement parce que je vais vous
présenter une phrase ça me prit un
couple de jours à mémoriser parce que
c'est tout un en français je vous ai dit
tantôt que vous vivez dans un corps à
l'ema vous avez un cerveau d'année malki
constamment les taux de survie pour se
sauver d'être mangés au pot sauvé a pris
quelqu'un pour le manger dont 7
cerfs-volants et vos ennemis non
travaillées comme humain c'est de
maîtriser le corps animal puis on passe
par au cerveau elle est mal le sourire
ça ça vaut bien les respirations c'est
du travail mais les pensées se peut être
plus complexe
vrai ou faux
fo comme un alcoolique qui veut se
rétablir
le première phase de rétablissement
c'est de l'admettre exactement ça si
vous êtes prêt à admettre que vous
n'êtes pas propriétaire de votre corps
que vous le louez pour aix nombre
d'années j'espère que c'est certain pour
tout le monde mais ce camp là que vous
louez elle a des défauts de
manufacturière qui provient de sites
itération à travers l'évolution humain
le feu du logis pee wee joueurs regardez
si pour capable prononcer quand j'ai vu
le premier jour je pense que c'était le
personnel logement à eau pour un conte
dans la langage commun nous solaire que
son hamster qui tombe dans la tête
mais cette folle du logis et facilement
délogeables par la respiration
j'ai un très bon contre respiration elle
s'appelle colette si vous savez poche de
quelqu'un qui étaient 47 ans et quelques
mots sur les nerfs elle me faisait
enlever la climatisation dans mon camion
elle m'envoie dans le trafic à 5,1 de
bonbons jusqu'à cape rouge qu'il fallait
que je pratique la respiration je peux à
présent
ç'a bien été
un que vous êtes peut-être moins soumis
hier avec céline neurones miroirs
si vous saviez que toutes nos cerveaux
sont comme des oies et phares bi
directionnelle et que nous sommes
constamment en interconnectivité que le
vous le vouliez ou non si quelqu'un dans
la salle bail
il se peut que quelqu'un d'autre accordé
bail non vous êtes dans le trafic puis
vous regardez quelqu'un à 45° devant
vous le personnes se virent de bord qui
vous garde des exemples vraiment banal
des neurones miroirs qui fait en sorte
qu'il ya beaucoup de stocks qui se passe
dans votre cerveau que nous vous ne
pouvez pas maîtrisé si nous vous n'avez
pas le contrôle
trois choses que la science nous donne
un le sourire j'en ai parlé
comme je vous avais dit fait quant à lui
m la respiration et le contrôle des
pensées au delà de la science dans les
dernières trois ans où est ce que j'ai
fait des changements profonds pour
augmenter mon taux de vibrations pour
travailler sur ma fréquence j'ai
rencontré le plus gros cadeau de toute
ma vie
quelques mots donnés dans une séance
malheureusement le personne n'est plus
avec nous il me dit laisse faire la
méditation laisse faire toutes ces
choses là on détruit par actif il dit
quand tu te réveilles le matin fait
quinze minutes de gratitude
pourquoi de la gratitude
puis quand cette couche le soir fait que
les autres minutes
depuis j'ai pratiqué c'est ce une chose
j'ai vu 1 transformation dans mon champ
électromagnétique comme vous ne pouvez
pas comprendre pourquoi parce que je
suis anglet ce que je me frappe les nüvi
le genou c'est vrai quand je le frappe
je regarde autres je dis qu'est ce que
mon environnement veut me dire
et je prends le temps de remercier le
chef parce que j'ai col de poêles à bois
pour le brûler
en étant sérieux
le bonheur c'est vraiment vraiment
simple c'est le graet ce sens de la vie
c'est un accomplissement de soi mais
au-delà de tout sont ce que j'ai
découvert après dix ans de recherche
après 56 pays après au dessus de 250
mille pages de lecture le bonheur sur
simple décision
je me suis réveillé un matin que j'étais
écoeuré d'être malin et j'ai décidé
c'est tu m'attaques jeudi souvenirs
accrocheur un peu parce qu'il m'arrive
je suis heureux donc moi ça fait
exactement deux ans et trois mois que je
suis heureux je vis toute sorte de
madame cela va être
j'ai regardé le ciel des tuiles caché
rentrée mais je suis heureux et si je
peux vous laisser avec un seul réflexion
si vous n'avez pas pris la décision
d'être heureux vous avez pris la
décision d'être malheureux je vous
souhaite d'être heureux aujourd'hui